so that Pursuit that takes many many
many many many years
I don't know if you've seen Giro Dreams
of Sushi the
doing the simple thing
that's not so simple but it kind of
looks simple of this over and over and
over and over and over and presumably
getting much better at this Tempo it
becomes very simple but you're picking
up details probably along the way
there's wisdom along the way
what is that is that um
there's like lessons that you just kind
of accumulate over time like one
training sessions you'll see
maybe
um
like the positioning
of the thumb like this detailed
positioning of the thumb or something
like this and then you like okay if you
like load that in
that that would be very basic because
there is not that many different ways
maybe one two I just do one any other is
not as strong because it's it's about
getting a strong grip on your call I
mean the sun is it's the thumb goes
inside you know is it the summon or or
four fingers in base getting a strong
grip on the call as long as they know
this
he's just holding yeah and feeling
strong so that's just two options so uh
it's the dynamic stuff along the way
that yeah and then some less timing too
it's timing are you also like making
people like faking them out making them
think about something else no not at
that point
that's not because I cannot fake
anything else at that point
because I'll have to change my
positioning to you know maybe to fake an
arm lock
then I have to move out from that so
then I will lose that the control I have
so what's the process towards Master if
you were to convert that to something
that generalizes Beyond jiu jitsu how
can you get
that good at a simple thing practice
and what that simple the same exact
thing over and over it's just a matter
of how long it would take
so all
that's true that's true I mean like I
said that's true look how long it took
me
people give up along the way